he wants
body camera video shows a deputy
involved shooting in California after a
suspect rushes at sheriff's deputies
with a metal bed frame how do we open
this door
the incident happened on April 26th in
eastern San Diego County just before 7
30 that night sheriff's deputies
responded to a call for a man
threatening to kill his roommates once
at the scene officials found the suspect
45-year-old Santo maroc holding a metal
bed frame drop that drop that you're not
in trouble it's just going to talk to
you okay drop it okay put it put it in
the bathroom put it in the bathtub put
it in the bathtub you're not in trouble
come talk to us video shows First
Responders working to de-escalate the
situation calling for morocc to put down
the bed frame here's what I want you to
do
to talk to me but you but you can't talk
to me
we'll make sure you are safe we'll make
sure you're we're gonna make sure you're
safe okay okay well you got you need to
drop that okay we can't we can't just
leave we want to make sure that you're
okay officials can be heard asking
morocc if he wants mental health
treatment did you want to speak to a
clinician
did you want to talk to clinician
okay what would you like us to do
what would you like how can I help you
First Responders continue to ask morocc
to drop the bed frame saying they feel
unsafe that's the only way no that's the
only way you gotta work with me
you got to work with me
okay
what is what am I going to find inside
that room
[Applause]
this one here yes what is in there what
is in there because I'm concerned for my
safety I'm concerned for myself okay
[Music]
you need to drop that frame okay
okay who else is in the house guys
officials then tell morocc they do not
want anyone to get hurt we do not want
to harm you
okay we're gonna help you if you're
holding on to that okay I don't want to
get hurt
I want to go home okay
as morocc suddenly rushes out of the
bedroom with the bed frame a deputy
fires a less Lethal Weapon in an effort
to stop him when morocc still moves
forward another deputy fires three shots
how do we open this door
he wants
this body camera video shows the point
of view of the sheriff's deputy who
opened fire on maroc
which door he wants
Barack was shot and injured in his lower
body after the shooting sheriff's
deputies begin first aid treatment
all right we gotta start rendering it is
check his legs
get outside you're gonna have to get the
people in here we got tourniquets on us
get Medics ready for us let's try and
move get a pat down down on him okay
he's good on this side he's good on this
side sounds good yeah let's check the
other side
we're gonna have to apply pressure to
these injuries guys minutes later
paramedics arrive on the scene
was taken to the hospital and treated he
was booked into the San Diego central
jail after his release and now faces
multiple charges including assault with
a deadly weapon on a peace officer and
making threats that can result in death
or great bodily harm the sheriff's
deputy involved in the shooting is now
on administrative Duty as the
investigation into the shooting
continues the San Diego Police
Department will conduct the
investigation and after that it will be
reviewed by the District Attorney's
Office reporting for a long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie